now this is an odd thing the way that  characters come back Dolores Umbridge  what is the connection between Dolores  Umbridge and Harry Potter and  coronavirus you tell me well media or  anything so I've no idea what's going on  well on Twitter there's lots of these  tweets if we followed Laura's um  purchase proclamations nobody would get  coronavirus did she bring in the social  decision did you invent it yes  absolutely she did and and and all for  the better I feel yeah coronavirus is  the Dolores Umbridge of the world right  now  also coronavirus had a name it would be  Dolores Umbridge oh okay okay I'm gonna  keep a low profile on that actually  social distancing for you as Dolores  Umbridge do people kind of scatter out  of your way in supermarkets anyway  absolutely do anyway so I've never I've  never touched I've never touched anyone  in industry and I've been working around  who are you you and I get to step away  step away and they do  [Music]  you